one last Quick story here on Trump
Donald Trump is now begging the Supreme
Court please hide my taxes please please
hide my taxes for someone who has
nothing to hide I have never seen anyone
go through this amount of trouble to
prevent their taxes from going public
CNN reporting former president Donald
Trump has asked the Supreme Court to put
on hold the release of his tax returns
by the IRS to a democratic lead house
committee
Trump filed the emergency request Monday
with the high court after a federal
appeals court as I told you cleared the
way last week for Trump's returns to be
disclosed to the house Ways and Means
Committee
the case is the most direct way for the
house to get Trump's federal tax returns
after trying other avenues for years the
Trump team wants the Supreme Court to
put the release of the tax returns on
pause while the justices consider
whether to take the case up
uh to review the lower court decision
this is this is the last Salva this
really is the last Salvo as far as every
legal analyst I've spoken to has told me
an appeals court has already ruled
asking the Supreme Court to look at it
is the a hundred percent last chance if
they don't take it up then the
Democratic house committee gets Trump's
tax returns do they probably leak from
there I don't know maybe they do I would
never encourage anybody to do anything
illegal and if they were to leak I would
absolutely look at them that's where I
will put it so this is Trump desperately
begging the Supreme Court to save him
what do we believe at this point would
be in those documents well I I don't
think it has changed number one the
documents might reveal Donald Trump is
not as wealthy as he claims to be at
this point we know that so I don't think
that that would be a big surprise
number two they might reveal income
sources that are inconvenient or
problematic for Trump What specifically
they would be is the stuff of
speculation
and number three they might further
confirm another thing we already know
which is Trump uses very different
values for assets depending on what his
objective is
all things we suspect but it would be
confirmation we have a great bonus show
for you today we will talk a little bit
more about Kanye West who is now
suspended from Instagram for
anti-submitic comments the high school
football coach who led the prayers on
the field
is getting his job back and we do it
every year we will again rant and Rave
about daylight saving time it is not a
settled issue it is very much not a
settled issue all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad the money is being
made and everybody here is good you can
sign up at joinpakman.com I will see you
then before you go if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more please make
sure to subscribe to my YouTube channel
you can click the Subscribe button below
or above or wherever it is on your
screen and if you want to support my
work even more strongly the best way is
to get a membership at joinpakman.com
And subscribe to the podcast for the
David packman show there you can check
out interviews longer clips and much
more it's on all the big podcasting
platforms just search for the David
packman show and all the links are also
Down Below in the video description